[Music]
for
over half a century we've searched for
radio signals
from extraterrestrial civilizations
but it's been well
a little quiet are they
ignoring us or have
aliens already made contact
without us knowing it the truth
could be hiding in plain sight
how has technology helped us look for
extraterrestrial life
could bacteria contain secret
alien messages and
what if aliens already live
among us this is what if
and here's what would happen if we've
already made first contact
with aliens since the 1960s
scientists at seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
have had their ears to the skies
listening for signals that could
prove the existence of extraterrestrial
life
recently bizarre and intermittent fast
radio bursts were detected
coming from a spiral galaxy like the
milky way
500 million light years from earth
some scientists wonder if these
pulsating signatures from space
are the result of many black holes or
pulsars
or even alien megastructures
but could these signals actually be
aliens trying to communicate with us
scientists at harvard theorized that the
energy needed to send
a radio signal to a distant galaxy would
require
a planet twice the size of earth covered
in energy collectors
while it is possible scientists have
found
an easier way for aliens to talk to us
and according to robert zubrin it
could involve teeny tiny interstellar
light sails
this idea has been gaining enough ground
that the
breakthrough starshot project is working
on nano spacecraft someday they hope to
beam them
all the way to alpha centauri
while tiny spacecraft could travel great
distances
bacteria could potentially survive the
journey as well
this is because it's easy for a
bacterium to duplicate itself
and as microorganisms they are small
enough to overcome
the gravity of stars making it possible
for them to travel
interstellar distances hypothetically
a microbial nanocraft could be beamed
from earth
and travel a distance of one light year
every ten thousand years
in fifty thousand years it could reach
nearby stars
but why would aliens be sending us
bacteria well the answer
is in dna just one gram of bacteria
could be encoded with about 900
terabytes of dna data
imagine a 200 page book
now imagine two billion of these books
that's how much data in fact
microbiologists think that
alien messages may already exist
hidden in dna here on earth
waiting to be decoded researchers
suggest
these messages could be found by
determining which bacteria could survive
the conditions of space
in fact some astrobiologists on the iss
have experimented to see if all life on
earth
could have come from extraterrestrial
microbes
this theory known as panspermia
suggests that microbes may have hitched
a ride on a comet that crashed into
earth
so like maybe we're the aliens
okay okay but are we really alone
while microbial alien messages could
exist
we're still not sure what these alien
messengers
might look like we're mostly familiar
with terrestrial life where
all living beings are made from cells
using
molecular machinery with most life here
on earth being carbon-based
we might just be looking for the wrong
kind of life
many biochemists suggest that
silicon-based life forms could exist
in fact some scientists including
british chemist and astronaut helen
sharman
suggests that aliens could exist in a
place
we cannot see or study known as
a shadow biosphere these invisible
aliens
could exist at a microscopic level
beyond our comprehension
with recent ufo sightings being
declassified by the pentagon
many people believe that aliens have
already visited us
maybe in the not too distant future
with the help of seti we'll finally
prove that
we're not alone
for more on this tune into our what if
discussed podcast
this week we talked to dr andrew siemian
astrophysicist and director of the
berkeley seti research center
he'll join us for a deeper dive into the
subject
and update us on seti's progress in its
comprehensive search
for alien communications
you